hey this is matt from animar today we're
talking to nate Bennett he has a channel
called okay Nate as part of the my damn
channel network hey Nate how's it going
today hey it's going pretty good how are
you pretty good pretty good so the okay
Nate show is kind of as like an eclectic
vibe what's the show all about if you
could just sum it up I guess okay Nate
sort of started as it's just me kind of
talking about things that excite me and
my general life and just what I think
about certain things and I guess I
people enjoy having a conversation with
me and so far I've had a lot of people
that are friends of mine that have seen
it and say it's just like visiting me or
having a very pleasant conversation so I
guess yeah me talking about things that
interest me or excite me or even just
anything at all but just kind of my take
on it so people seem to enjoy that very
cool very cool so how did you first get
start with my damn channel oh it's funny
I was actually an associate producer on
another show and the director from that
show ended up working as the director my
time channel live and he knew I was
interested in writing and producing
comedy stuff so i started at My Damn
Channel live as a PA and so I was
production assistant for a few months
and then started being more active in
the show like I got written to the show
a couple times as a few joke bits the
audience start recognizing me on the
show so then from there they were like
hey you should start a vlog so I just
started producing okay Nate and then
from there just kind of build my
audience from my name Channel live and
also from just general YouTube viewers
right right of course um you know like I
was saying you kind of have a really
eclectic five of what you do you
Valentine's Day you did how to ask a
girl out then recently did an unboxing
that you got from your mom that was
really funny how do you decide what
you're gonna vlog about every day do you
plan things in advance or just
interesting things that happened that
day I try to plan it out but a lot of
times it's just like oh this seems
interesting I'll do it right now for the
Valentine's Day vlog we kind of planned
that one out ahead of time like grace we
knew that grace was going to be and
hannah we're going to be in from my own
channel live so i just messaged them
ahead of time when they were in town and
you know said hey I want to shoot this
thing for down the road and planned it
out I guess for bigger projects like
that I'll plan it out but then sometimes
there'll be things that happen spur the
moment that would be great like the box
I wasn't expecting a package I got when
I was like I'll be fun to kind of open
it riff on it cuz I
my mom will probably send me something
specific or weird like shampoo so it I
say its a mix of both I like L so if you
saw my grumpy cat video that was just
kind of we discovered we got in touch
with the people that own grumpy cat and
managed to do that last man we just kind
of threw that together I would say a lot
of them are plans like I had a list of
what I want to do and then sometimes
it's just whatever's coming up let me
ask you this question because I saw the
grumpy cat 1 and I and there's this
strange phenomenon about grumpy cat that
I'm trying to figure out you oh god you
met the cat's owner correct yep do you
believe that she has some sort of cat
spirit animal within her because let me
go with this number one she refers to
herself as tabby and not Tabitha and at
some point during our email
correspondence she said that sounds
perfect puuu r f ECT do you think she's
actually grumpy cat is actually her
spirit animal I would not be surprised
if grumpy cat was not her spirit animal
I would say yes i would say they have
they share very similar characteristics
they were both extremely exhausted when
we came to visit them which is apparent
the video at least of grumpy cat that
cat looked like it was gonna die at any
moment I thought it was gonna die I felt
so bad I was like oh man is she gonna be
okay to do this she's like no she's like
this all the time so it was like okay
she just didn't very mellow cat and also
had a very long day running around New
York all sales watching videos like that
cat is either dying or dead and you're
just kind of like doing the weekend at
Bernie's with it haha I I hope it
doesn't come out looking like I'm just
shaking around a cat that's really
trying to sleep uh whole time out like
are you okay with this is a cool no like
yeah it's fine she's cool she was a
little more active before that too so we
hung out a little bit I was a little
worried though because I'm also allergic
to cats so when I was shooting that
video like I had taken some stuff but I
was slowly getting more and more like
your body my body being like hey you
should probably move away from here
right now and so I was doing these takes
of laying down with tartar sauce a thing
my buddy what are you doing no no no but
I just stuck it out anyway because it
was just it was fun and you know they
were very nice and the cat was very nice
you should have wrapped it up like the
end of the rock with the eff up my tin
to the heart where you have to make
yourself come back to life with it can I
just hold flares up little bro peek at
that'd be great so we
do that we've talked to the ton of
people from My Damn Channel and it seems
like my damn channel is like a big girls
club like there seems like there's a lot
of girls host and a lot of shows host my
girls do you kind of feel like the My
Damn Channel kid brother I've never
heard it put that before uh I guess I'm
one of the like on the vlog and I am one
of the few do other dudes I mean we have
nick from slack turi he's like our token
like expert internet nerd guy who's
great and Joe who's over there too so I
don't know I'm one of the few I guess
you could say I am kind of that I've
never heard that label before but I
guess everybody over there like all the
other like people I hang out with ever
they're like grace and that stuff they
do kind of treat me like that so that's
that's a good label thanks hey no
problem with that uh with grace she's
like killed at the streamys she called
my kid really really well she's like the
breakout hit of this year how much
jealousy is currently Harvard at My Damn
Channel that did she just walk by any
okay congratulations and then she'll
leave and you'll just bite your fist
like that in jealousy what no no way we
all like working with grace like up
until recently we were working with her
once a week on my name's Channel live
and she's just so nice and so funny and
awesome so if anything we're just like
yeah because we feel like it's part of
the team yeah right so it's like it's
more of a team mentality like oh man
good on her well deserved awesome yeah
you guys are much more how would I say
mature than most people I would be just
to be with the jealousy constantly yeah
I secret I sent her a box of chocolates
that are poisonous I can take her place
that's exactly no there's no ulterior
motives um you're at the studio's right
now what is kind of like shooting every
day like with my damn channel we were
doing our live show five days a week and
now we're kind of on hiatus it was
pretty crazy for a while you know we'd
have a lot of like we try to like plan
out the day before it was a lot of
breakdown of okay what are we doing
tomorrow what are we doing the next day
Wednesday was our big show for a while
so we would plan that out the week
before and then we were doing like these
daily hangouts which relied a lot on
comments and viewers we got into this
groove towards the end where I would be
part of being a comment DJ and Beth
would host and we would just kind of
rift with the people and play it was a
pretty hectic schedule doing five days a
week with you know we'd also go out and
shoot
it's and talk to other comedians and
things like that so it was it was crazy
town and its kind of calm down a little
bit we still shoot as much stuff as we
can here you know every day I guess I
can't really give you a breakdown
because it feels like just a blur of
what was happening at the time was just
a lot a lot of work it was great it was
so much fun it's been fun and hopefully
we'll be back at some point in some
iteration yeah right on right on do you
have anything that's coming up that
you're really psyched about that you
can't with people to check out that we
should keep an eye on the floor I don't
wanna like spoiling them you know some
of them are like topic I want to I want
to do something addressing google
glasses that's one thing i want to talk
about at least why i should have some
okay or at least my skewed perception of
why i should have won some i'm
definitely gonna probably end up talking
about Game of Thrones then when it comes
back out because he was not excited for
that right stuff like that I don't know
no I don't have any huge projects that
I'm gonna talk about right now I'm just
waiting did you see the new trailer for
a game of thrones season 3 no they have
that yeah check out io9 it's on io9
right now uh I've been on Io name
forever yes that's the next I'm gonna do
literally after this it's gonna be cool
I can't wait I read all the books I'm
ready okay so my last question in terms
of superpowers would you rather have all
of Aquaman's superpowers okay or have no
superpowers and just be married to
wonder woman is this the Aquaman that
has like no hand but somehow has magic
water like he got later on or is it just
the Aquaman that literally talks to fish
and hasn't tried it talking fish Trident
one okay married to wonder woman okay
easy done deal yeah I think that a
really smart choice I think so too and
mean she can fly that's pretty great and
also she's yeah you know although she
might kind of be in charge because she's
super strong and I'm not so yeah I guess
the practicality of that I don't know
pros outweigh the cons i'm sticking with
Wonder Woman well cool cool that is that
is my last question so thanks for
talking the snake really appreciate it
where can we check out the channel oh
thanks you check me out on youtube.com
slash okay Nate hey thanks for checking
out our skype interview with Nate
Bennett we got plenty more interviews
over at our channel youtube.com slash
new media rock stars go there subscribed
and start checking stuff out